president-elect joe biden says his
transition team is now in touch with
officials across
every single federal agency the next
president revealed his secretary of
state and other top diplomatic officials
yesterday
and says he'll name members of his
economic team in the week to come
nicole killian is covering the
transition for us in wilmington delaware
america is back ready to lead the world
president-elect biden formally
introduced his foreign policy
and national security team on tuesday
the six nominees displayed
a major change in tone from the trump
administration
i have never shied away from speaking
truth to power if confirmed
they would include the first woman to
lead the intelligence community
the first latino homeland security
secretary and the first climate envoy to
have a seat on the national security
council
former secretary of state john kerry in
addressing the climate crisis
president-elect joe biden is determined
to seize the future
now the president-elect's team also
highlights
a marked shift in policy america is back
multilateralism is back diplomacy
is back the group was announced a day
after the general services
administration
gave the green light for the formal
transition to begin
and in an interview with nbc news's
lester holt mr biden says
members of his staff are already working
with the trump administration
the outreach has been sincere there's
not been begrudging so far and i don't
expect it to be
the president-elect was non-committal
about nominating progressives elizabeth
warren or bernie sanders to his cabinet
taking someone out of the senate taking
someone out of the house
a particularly personal consequence
is a really difficult decision but he
said he would consider nominating a
republican for a post perhaps even one
who voted for president trump
meanwhile the president who still
refuses to concede
made an impromptu 64 second appearance
in the white house briefing room
touting the stock market the stock
market's just broken 30 thousand never
been broken that number
that's a sacred number mr trump also
participated in the annual turkey pardon
corn i hereby grant you a full
pardon two
of president trump's advisers confirmed
to cbs news that the president
is expected to join his attorney rudy
giuliani in gettysburg pennsylvania
today for a republican hearing
on election fraud it would mark his
first trip
outside of the washington area since the
election president-elect biden remains
here in delaware
where he'll deliver a thanksgiving
address tony all right nicole thank you
very much